hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time let me quickly
introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trainer for the past six years in hong
kong
and right now i do some youtube videos
because i think that it's very
interesting
for you guys to actually see how
professional traders are making money on
the market
and what kind of tools and techniques we
use to
set up our trades and in my videos i
want to
show you how to do it yourself and i'm
only gonna show you what is really
working for me and for those who are
watching my video for some time
you actually know that i've been pretty
spot on on
every asset i cover or you know stock or
crypto
and in this video i want to make a
massive update guys on amc
and as usual show you all the different
scenarios that can happen
using my forecasting tools and show you
how to select the best one
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so we had a pretty strong
day yesterday on amc
plus 18 plus 22 sorry and aftermarket
was very strong as well
so very quickly let me remind you here
the situation so we went to 35 this is
the level i was calling you guys for you
know very long time around like you know
two months and i told you in the past
three weeks
you can go and check my videos that we
are in the third wave
so i'm talking about this wave here guys
one
two three run this wave we don't know
where it's going
right now i'm going to show you all the
different scenarios and i'm going to
show you guys what you really want to
see
is basically what you need to do right
now if you have some amc shells
and so yeah we are in the third wave we
went to 35 as expected we got rejected
to 26
as expected and so right now let's see
what can
happen one technique i really like to
use so i'm gonna give you here
something that you know pro traders
actually do a lot is to use a trading
stop loss all right
so if you have inc shares so i know you
guys don't like to sell
but maybe some of you are considering
where to take
some profits or maybe you know to reload
maybe
lower and here you can see
that you know when you have those strong
moves up
you always have something it can be a
trend line or moving average
that is supporting the price very well
and in this
case it's the 20 period moving average
on the hourly time frame
you can see that in the past week we had
one
two three
four reactions this one counts guys
because you know for
a support to be broken you need to have
two consecutive candles that are closing
below it
so here we didn't have it so okay here
we had some a bit of excess but this was
after market
so you know it's not really to be taken
into account
and to choose your moving average you
can have a look as well at the past
and something that was working well in
the past is usually going to give you
very good signals again and here for
example during the strong move up we had
in january
you can see that the 20 period moving
average was actually acting as support
very well during this whole move up as
well and it actually allowed you guys to
keep your shares to very
high levels so here as long as we are
above this moving average
guys we are bullish so let's see what
the price action is going to show us
but this is one signal very short-term
signal that you can use
to exit your position if you want to
then let me make here the different
scenarios because once again guys
the way i found 35 and the way i
actually showed you
all the signals that the third wave is
coming
is basically by using uh trend lines and
idiot wave principle
associated as well with fibonacci
retracement and extensions and here i'm
going to keep using the same techniques
that worked once so when something is
working it's usually keeping
working so here let's do some idiot wave
counting
so the first thing i want to show you
and i'm going to build different
scenarios with you guys
so on the hourly time frame we're going
to start to count what we're having here
and we're gonna see what we can have so
here one two
then here i can make one two three
four five so this is a three
okay so in one of the scenarios we are
having something like this all right
this is the most bullish scenario but
when i see the price action in the you
know that happened on tuesday
especially what happened after market
which means that a lot of market makers
need to buy
you know maybe hedge funds i don't know
but some big
clients of some big institutional
clients or hedge funds needed
to buy amc shares not to be left short
probably because they were short
you know when you have so strong moves
in after hours
it means that some big players are short
and probably because of the
gamma in this case and here we're
wondering how high this can go because
as i told you you can follow a training
stop loss or
you can also try to find some targets
and take your profits
once you reach the target so here to
know where this fifth wave might go we
just measure the third wave
applied to the bottom of the force wave
and it gives us
some levels the 1.618 is the most common
fib extension level so we put it here
all right first scenario then i'm going
to do the same thing but i'm going to
consider
that actually this purple wave is
complete all right so that the one two
three four five is actually inside it
you know i'm gonna consider we're having
something like this
which is possible as well guys because
we don't know exactly what
is playing out that's why we need to
have some
signals some indicators that are going
to give us those early signals
that things are changing so here let's
keep this one like this
and let's make another one so one
two three so now we imagine this one is
complete let me put it in a different
color
so if this is playing out then it means
that the correction is going to be a bit
longer and that here probably you see we
have this abc pattern
we might have a flat because as you know
guys in force wave
we might have zigzag flat or triangle
patterns
this cannot be a triangle this cannot be
a zigzag so the only thing it can be is
a flat
alright so this is possible especially
we have a zigzag here so usually when
second waves are zigzag
force waves are flats so here this is
another scenario and if i measure
the third wave here so this time is
this one it's going to bring me to
slightly higher levels so i do the same
thing 1.618 so this time is 66
and then i keep doing this guys on the
larger degree wave counting because once
again
i don't know if this wave is complete or
not right
three okay then if it's this one
which means that this one is complete
which is very unlikely
but it's possible as well i think most
likely we're going to have something
like this for this one so it's going to
be very interesting to see
where this third wave here is actually
going
because once we know where it's going we
can actually predict better
where the force wave retracement might
go before the
fifth wave arrives so for now
let's assume that it's complete because
this is
as well a possibility guys it's very
unlikely the scenario is very unlikely
given the strong rebound that we had
here all right it really looks like here
something
more is playing out but i'm still gonna
give you this scenario because i think
it's interesting but
we can already almost eliminate this one
and same thing and then i'm gonna
measure the third wave
up and then i'm not sure where i'm gonna
apply it all right so it really depends
if we correct only to here
it brings me to higher levels so i'm not
sure where we're gonna correct
i'm not sure exactly if this is still on
the table or not
we might have you know some kind of a
triangle maybe here in the first wave
then it would mean that this third wave
here so let me put it in a different
color
the third wave of the blue five wave
development
would actually be complete which is to
me
uh hard to believe you know because i
can still find some counting where it
works
you know for example this one
okay so then it could be complete but
guys to be honest it doesn't look good
it doesn't fit well so this is how you
eliminate some of the scenarios
so i don't think actually this one is on
the table
but even if it is we still go to 70 guys
so it's important to notice and let me
show you the last one
up
right then this one would probably
correct deeper
no choice okay so if this one is playing
out
because here we have a 1 2 as well then
guys
measure the third wave and i applied to
the bottom of the force wave and then it
brings me to
you know 65 as well so i gave you here
four scenarios number four and three
let me put it maybe in a different
purple
and this scenario guys are very unlikely
because they would mean
that this one and this one are of the
table and
what i see here so let me just show you
guys here
what i see here with this strong move up
is that something
more is playing out here that this move
is not complete
and that we actually gonna break 35
maybe this week and go higher so i'm
gonna give you here
one more technique to actually know
before it happens when the market is
actually gonna shift
so you need to find some reversal signs
so once again
you can see for example some bearish
divergences but here you won't have
those i'm not gonna go through
what is the divergence with you guys but
those who are watching my
videos for some time know that it's
actually very
trustful signals that i used here to
predict as well
the bullish momentum that started here
so
we're not going to use those here
they're not applying in this situation
but you can use for example some
candlestick reversal patterns
so i'm going to show you better to do
this on a daily time frame
so let me maybe get rid of my countings
and here for example you're looking for
example bearish engulfing pattern
so it's for example a candle that is
going to eat this candle
completely you know a bearish red candle
or you can find you know some island
reversal so this for example is an
island reversal is when you have an
isolated
candle alone above so let me show you
what is an island reversal
okay so an island reversal something
like this when you have some isolated
candles you know with some gap up here
and gap down here
that actually show you that there were
some
buyers that got stuck here so that's why
it's
an island you know you have those three
candles alone
and it's a very powerful reversal
patterns so this is the kind of things
you can look for
but most importantly when you have so
strong
moves up guys it takes time before the
reversal actually happens
and usually you have a lot of red days
before the real reversal happens so you
can
take your time and check if those red
days are happening
here for example we had one this one is
not good all right
it means the market opens with a lot of
bullish momentum
and that sellers right away sees the
opportunity to sell their shares
so this is not a good signal but here we
had a green day coming right away
you can see for example guys it's
very you know we have a beautiful
example on amc
just a few months ago and you can see
guys for example here we had this red
day
followed by this red day this red day
and you know
five red days in a row and you can see
each time the market was opening high
and closing lower so this is a bearish
sign
and this was actually what i was really
watching
if you know the market is able to close
higher
than the level it actually opened and we
did it
on tuesday's session so this is very
good and this is why
i think that those scenarios that i had
here
you know are actually really on the
table guys
because we had one more strong day that
shows that
the market still wants to develop higher
right now let me show you guys
uh some very interesting data so for
those who are watching my video for some
time you know that
i like to keep an eye on the option
market because actually guys this is
what created
those strong moves up we had a gamma
squeeze guys we had a gamma squeeze
because you can see
here i'm actually having all the strikes
of all the maturities guys
i take all the maturities june july
september
jan 22 gen 23 i take all the open
interest i multiply this by 100
and by the price level and
the delta all right so to compute the
delta i use this formula
guys that is here you know i'm not gonna
go through this again
here with you but i basically compute
all the synthetic
short position exposure and as of friday
amc was at 26
so we had 1.7 billion usd
short exposure on amc and now we are
at 37 guys so you can see we go from
1.7 billion to 3 billion
guys this is what is called the gamma
right the higher
amc goes the more shares market makers
need to buy right now they need to buy
82 million
shares guys 18 of the total share float
which is a lot
and you can see here that we having
some very very heavy open interest on
the 40 strike
and guys now we opened uh the
new strikes you know we go up to 17 so
they just opened yesterday
so for now we don't have any exposure
here nothing and
remember guys i was telling you that you
know this is a very bullish sign
that this is what can create a gamma
squeeze if you don't have those very big
uh positions on the upside calls it's
gonna be hard for the market to actually
you know
gamma squeeze like it just did and right
now we don't have any
positions here because those strikes are
new listed strikes
but i'm going to keep an eye on this i'm
going to follow this very closely
if we see on the 70 strike some very big
positions starting to be
built then it means guys that this is
gonna happen
again so this is a very good indicator
to watch
and i'm gonna keep an eye on this for
you another indicator that i like to
watch is the volatility and
right now you can see i was taking the
40 strike volatility so it's the one
that i have here
of the 40 strike we have 32 million
shares equivalent guys so it's really a
lot
and this volatility is of course at very
high levels because amc is moving a lot
every day
but i'm also going to keep an eye now on
the 70 strike
call and if i see that this is you know
going higher
suddenly it's a signal that market
makers are
actually using protection against those
strikes which means that
they're gonna buy shares if amc goes
higher so it's another indicator that i
like to use
all right guys so that's it for me i
hope you enjoyed this video i tried here
to sum up all the situations so i remind
you
that i have you know different scenarios
that are here
and that as long as we stay above the 20
period moving average we are bullish
we are probably going to 65 i'm not sure
if it's this week
next week next month we need to follow
this
we are looking for reversal patterns
that are going to tell us
if maybe we are shifting uh momentum or
not
uh we also looking for those red days
that we don't want to see but if we see
too many of those we know that the
market is going to shift
soon as well and we keep an eye on the
option market that
is actually telling us if yes or not a
gamma squeeze is likely to happen again
and push imc to even higher levels
so i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys